Created by cartoon veteran Loren Bouchard,
Bob's Burgers mixes silly stories, puns, heart,
and music to make for a truly original and
wholesome viewing experience.
Get ready to dive between the buns, because
we're taking a look at the untold truth of
Bob's Burgers.
The way a TV show gets made is pretty straightforward...and
difficult.
A writer comes up with an idea for a show,
writes a pilot script, and, if they've got
enough credits and clout in Hollywood, they've
got an agent, and that agent gets the pilot
into the hands of the executives at TV networks
who decide what shows they might want to make.
This is not how Bob's Burgers originated.
Creator Loren Bouchard was actually approached
by Suzanna Makkos, the executive vice president
in charge of comedy at Fox, and asked to create
an animated series for the network.
Makkos was working on developing another animated
series and was looking at demo reels by animation
houses.
One of them included some clips of Lucy, the
Daughter of the Devil, a macabre comedy that
had briefly run on Adult Swim.
Makkos liked the animation fine, but what
she really liked was the show.
She thought it was funny and had an assistant
track down its creator, Loren Bouchard.
He was living in San Francisco at the time
and flew down to meet with Makkos about making
a show that same day.
Because cartoons are so expensive and complicated
to produce, some will forgo making a complete
30-minute pilot in favor of a "pilot presentation,"
a short, roughly animated film of just a few
minutes that gives network executives a good
idea of what a completed series would feel
like.
Bouchard and producer Jim Dauterive made one
such pilot presentation for Fox.
Fox entertainment head Kevin Reilly liked
the overall concept and feel of the show,
but he had some notes.
Among them were that the three kids' personalities
were not unique enough from one another.
At that time, the Belcher kids consisted of
one girl, Louise, and two boys, Gene and Daniel.
While Bouchard had to admit that Reilly was
correct, neither he nor Fox wanted to let
go of Dan Mintz, who played Daniel.
The solution: change Daniel to a girl named
Tina, keep Mintz in the part, and don't have
him change his voice or approach to the character
at all.
"I'm no hero.
I put my bra on one boob at a time, just like
everyone else."
The last thing that Bouchard had worked on
before Bob's Burgers was Lucy, Daughter of
the Devil for Adult Swim.
That show was about the battle between good
and evil, and so at the time, Bouchard had
trained himself to skew his comedy on the
more twisted side.
That led to a very dark initial premise for
Bob's Burgers: The Belchers were going to
run a burger joint...but they were cannibals.
Bouchard explained:
"I had this kind of more occult-y, sort of
darker edge to the way I was thinking then."
Ultimately, Fox loved everything about the
show except the cannibalism.
Suzanna Makkos talked Bouchard out of it,
pointing out how difficult it would be to
do, quote, "100 episodes' worth of cannibal
jokes."
Elements of the original concept remains:
Mort's Funeral Home next door was possibly
going to be a meat supplier for Bob's Burgers.
The very first episode even pays homage to
the original premise!
"Why'd you get run out of Bog Harbor?"
"For selling human flesh to the restaurants."
"Haha, I'm kidding, people!
Come on!"
The voice cast of Bob's Burgers was initially
populated by veteran professional comedians
and voice actors.
But that's not the case for the actor who
landed the role of boisterous, prone-to-singing
Linda Belcher.
"I'm a Ta-Ta and I'm gonna rock ya!
I'm singing from the heart!
I still got two outta five, I still got two
outta five, I still got two out of five sexy
parts!
Woo!"
A lot of people start making YouTube videos
with visions of stardom.
The dream has only come true so far for a
relative handful and John Roberts, who voices
Linda, is one of them.
His videos, such as "The Christmas Tree" and
"The Phone Call," in which he played overbearing
older women, went viral and led to appearances
on a number of shows playing those kinds of
characters, such as on Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon, where he played the host's mother.
That all led to a meeting with Loren Bouchard,
and a role on Bob's Burgers playing a character
much like the ones he created online.
In 2015, Roberts became the first member of
the Bob's Burgers cast to earn an Emmy Award
nomination for outstanding character voice-over
performance.
The show's cast consists primarily of major
players on the "alternative" comedy scene,
such as Kristen Schaal, Dan Mintz, and Eugene
Mirman, along with voice acting legend H.
Jon Benjamin.
Also part of the cast is Academy Award-winning
actor and theater star Kevin Kline.
Bob's Burgers represents his first major voice
work for a weekly animated TV series.
They got him to join the cast in a very non-traditional
way.
Kline's grown children live in New York and
go to a lot of comedy shows, and are big fans
of Mirman in particular.
They brought their father along to some shows,
and Kline and Mirman got along.
As it turns out, Kline's manager was friends
with the Bob's Burgers casting director, so
the show went out on a limb and asked him
if he'd be interested in the recurring role
of Bob's eccentric millionaire landlord, Mr.
Fischoeder.
"The truth is, Bob, I was only raising the
rent so you would notice me."
"Really?"
"No.
I wanted a pool.
You can't get chicks with a hedge maze."
"Sure, makes sense."
Kline read the script, thought it was funny,
and accepted, to the apparent disbelief of
the crew.
Bouchard admitted:
"I don't think any of us were prepared for
him to say yes."
The vast majority of animated TV series, past
and present, do not record their actors doing
their voice parts all at once.
Rather, each individual actor goes into a
recording studio and delivers lines one by
one.
Bob's Burgers is an exception audio for each
episode is collected from the entire cast
all at once.
It's not quite a table read with microphones,
or like shooting a live-action sitcom some
of the actors live in Los Angeles, and some
live in New York, so a high-quality ISDN line
is used to unite everybody.
But it is all done live, with the actors feeding
off each other.
This gives the show a realistic, conversational
feel with plenty of room for improvisation
similar to Bouchard's previous natural-sounding
series, Home Movies and Dr. Katz: Professional
Therapist.
Even big celebrities popping in for an episode
have to work this unique method of production
into their busy schedules.
Denizens of the Internet have a number of
theories about why youngest Belcher child
Louise always wears bunny ears.
It's never quite explained why; maybe she
has a bald spot she's hiding, or the hat allows
her to hide from the world in some small way.
The real reason is not so emotionally complicated.
It was inspired by a manga and later, anime
from Japan called Tekkonkinkreet.
Show creator Loren Bouchard explained:
"There was a kid who had this little bear
hat, and I liked that weird combination of
kid and animal where they become an animal
by always being seen wearing these little
ears.
You get a little cognitive dissonance where
you experience Louise both as a little girl
and Bugs Bunny at the same time."
That animal instinct is alive and well in
Louise, as are references to Japanese pop
culture in Bob's Burgers.
One episode features an extended dream sequence/tribute
to Studio Ghibli's My Neighbor Totoro, the
similarly Ghibli-inspired episode that takes
place inside Louise's fever-riddled brain,
and Bob and Louise's love of a series of Japanese
martial arts films called Hawk & Chick.
"I know we're fighting this seaweed monster
right now, but I want you to know how much
I love and support you even if you decide,
hold on.
Huh!
Hiya!"
Whether or not it has something to do with
one of those things, Bouchard mentioned on
Twitter in 2018 that the true origin of Louise's
bunny ears hat habit will be explained in
Bob's Burgers: The Movie, which hits theaters
in July 2020.
One of the most popular recurring features
on Bob's Burgers is the daily burger special
at Bob's Burgers.
Bob always finds a way to incorporate new
or special ingredients to make an interesting
and tasty burger.
In 2015, a Bob's Burgers fan named Cole Bowden
started a blog called The Bob's Burgers Experiment.
He dutifully recreated dozens of burger-of-the-day
specials based almost entirely on his own
imagination and culinary skills as on the
show, the burgers were little more than brief,
passing background gags.
In 2016, Bowden teamed up with the show's
creative team to release an official cookbook,
The Bob's Burgers Burger Book.
Along with new illustrations and text from
the Belcher family, it includes more than
70 real recipes such as "I Know Why the Cajun
Burger Sings Burger," "Sweaty Palms Burger,"
and "Shoot-Out at the OK-ra Corral Burger
(comes with fried okra)."
Hollywood is full of great actors, but it
takes a special eye for talent to match performers
to the right part.
Casting is a major part of the undefinable
magic of a great TV series, but the way Bob's
Burgers creator Loren Bouchard assembled his
cast was a little nontraditional and extremely
optimistic.
He wrote every main role with the actor who
would ultimately voice those characters in
mind.
Buchard told It's Nice That:
"I've worked with Jon Benjamin who plays Bob
for over 20 years.
I've only ever done shows with Jon in them,
I don't even want to know what it's like to
do a show without him.
I knew I wanted him as the dad and we built
the family around him."
He thought the female voice John Roberts did
in so many of his videos would work for Linda
Belcher, and that Kristen Schaal just ought
to be Louise.
He's also worked with Gene's Eugene Mirman
before, and wanted to include him in the main
family.
The only cast member not pre-approved: Dan
Mintz, who plays Tina, and was recommended
by Benjamin.
Fan art, new art created by fans, inspired
by and starring characters from their favorite
TV shows, is a wonderful thing.
But Bob's Burgers producer and artist Tony
Gennaro loves Bob's Burgers just as much as
viewers do, and makes what might be described
as "fan art" if he wasn't a member of the
show's staff.
You see, after each episode's script is written
and printed out for a table read by the cast,
Gennaro makes a special, original title page
illustration.
None of these images are based on actual stills
or animation from the episode or any of its
promotional materials.
It's just an extra little bit of Bob's Burgers
fun strictly for the people who make Bob's
Burgers.
They often mimic a movie poster, or pay homage
to the well-known posters used to promote
famous movies.
Gennaro's title page for "Uncle Teddy" recalls
the Uncle Buck one-sheet, for example, while
the "Seaplane!" art is a clear send-up of
Top Gun imagery.
Bob's Burgers seamlessly weaves the high with
the low.
Any given episode may present an earnest and
emotionally honest plot about the importance
of family and being a good person...but then
give way to something like Tina Belcher dreaming
about sexy zombies, or a song from Gene Belcher
about the glory of passing gas, for example.
This mix of high-minded and low-minded material
is prevalent in an unexpected place: an overlooked
bit of basic character information.
The last name of the central characters is
Belcher.
Why did creator Loren Bouchard stick them
with that?
He told It's Nice That.
First, the, quote, "silly stupid joke" of
the name appealed to him, but more importantly,
it was to provide some kind of cultural identification.
Bouchard explained:
"My name is French-Canadian and we wanted
them to have some ethnicity but couldn't settle
on what."
He and the writers selected a name that sounded
at least a little French-Canadian, in addition
to being a burp joke.
"We're Belchers, from the womb to the tomb!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.